[Applause]
nicholas sarkozy failed to be re-elected
as french president in 2012 despite a
lavish campaign the scale of his rallies
was designed to impress but instead it
set off alarm bells a police
investigation accused sarkozy and his
campaign team of spending more than
double the 27 million legal limit set by
the french state and hiring a pr company
called big malian to help cover up the
overspending with a system of fake
invoices symbolically it's important to
say that a president
doesn't get any immunity
and has to respond to the law
it is also important because the
campaign for 2022 is coming so we have
to have this reflection about
how to prevent illegal financing of a
political campaign in may sarkozy faced
trial in paris for a legal campaign
funding alongside 13 co-accused among
them one of his former campaign managers
jerome lavroller who admitted a role in
the system of fake invoices but said it
had not been his idea in his only court
appearance during the one month trial
sarkozy denied any wrongdoing he said he
wasn't involved in or aware of the
overspending cover-up but prosecutors
said that sarkozy failed to supervise
his campaign financing and ignored
warnings from his accountants
sarkozy served one term as president
from 2007
a straight talker with a love of luxury
he was tough on immigration and crime he
retired from politics in 2017. in recent
years the political right wing has
struggled in france but sarkozy's
remained prominent for a lot of french
citizens who
vote for the right side nicolas sarkozy
is seen as this kind of
all-time somehow reassuring figure if
sarkozy is found guilty in the big
malian trial he could face a six-month
jail term it would be another blow to
his reputation in march he was convicted
of corruption in a different case and he
could be back in court soon he's accused
of receiving illegal campaign funds from
the late libyan leader muhammad gaddafi
sarkozy's legal problems it seems are
far from over natasha butler al jazeera
paris